ideally i wanted it to rain but it's not
raining it's sunny so the closest thing
i can think of
[Music]
hello everyone my name is nori and
lately i've been writing these short
pieces based on your requests this week
i chose to write one inspired by the
prelude from maurice revels lutombo de
cupra
thank you to camilo for submitting this
idea so the first thing for me to do was
to learn the prelude which was really
great because i've actually been wanting
to learn it for a very long time but i
never got around to doing so until now
[Music]
without getting too caught up in the
details i focused on the different
things i love about this movement in a
broad sense
some of these include the figure eight
like pattern that creates a kind of
perpetual motion throughout the piece
the charming mortons that add a magical
touch and the circular progressions that
give the piece an unstable yet content
feel
just some notes about this keyboard
first of all for those of you who've
been commenting about the hidden piano
function yes i did know about it and i
use it pretty often but a lot of times i
choose to use the other sounds because
it's just very hard to get used to this
piano sound with this touch
it sounds like this by the way
[Music]
and
another thing about this keyboard is
that there is very very little
resistance
and that's okay if you're used to it but
i'm used to the weight of an upright or
a grand piano and with that comes some
habits such as me resting my my hands
and my fingers on the keys while i'm
playing between
bits where i'm playing and when i do
that on this keyboard sometimes it's too
much and i end up pressing the notes
so a lot of fast passages are very
difficult on this keyboard
and leaps as well
let me see what else um
i have a petal
made by yamaha
i just have one of these smaller ones
that i use
and that is about
it
and now here's the piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks so much for watching follow the
link in the description to find the
sheet music to this piece along with
some of my other works in written form
thank you so much for the support and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you